on Saturday socialist septuagenarian
loon bag senator Bernie Sanders
independent of crazy lab took to Twitter
to fire off a missive about how evil and
terrible Americans are here's what he
tweeted quote we are living in a nation
which worships wealth rather than caring
for the poor I don't think that is the
nation we should be living in well he
can move isn't the first time Sanders
has expressed this idea in January
sander said America was called not a
compassionate Society and stated quote
our record is worse than virtually any
other country on Earth this is stupid
first off Sanders obviously worships
government power rather than caring for
the poor the notion that the socialist
nations with which he sympathized
throughout his youth cared more for the
poor than the greatest prosperity
generating nation in the history of
mankind is absurd on his face sandra's
merely wishes he ran the world's wealth
because he thinks he could allocate it
better than billions of people
exchanging free in free exchange goods
and services all around the planet in
fact he routinely stands against such
free exchange second the American people
actually don't worship wealth in the way
Sanders does Marxists are materialists
they think that all of human happiness
amounts to material well-being the
American people willingly give of
themselves far more than residents of
any other country the American Almanac
kelantan philanthropic philanthropy that
found that Americans quote out donate
Britain in Canada to 21 and nations like
Italy in Germany 20 21 what's more more
than half of every single income class
except those earning less than 25 grand
donate to charity greedy evil one
percenters we give one third of all that
charity and the wealthiest
one-point-four percent of americans are
responsible for eighty-six percent of
the charitable donations made at death
America is by far the most religious
country in the industrialized world the
notion we sit around worshipping money
is a leftist conceit that identifies
good middle-class living built around
church and family as Babbitt rate but
Sanders engages in just that sort of a
battery while ignoring community on his
own he owns three homes and as for his
claims that Americans are selfish he
donated about eighty three hundred bucks
to charity in 2014 on earnings of two
hundred and five thousand dollars that
is half the percentage of income given
to charity that the Clintons handed over
not exactly the record of a man who
proclaims the wealth means nothing and
that the trappings of materialism must
be shed in favor of redistribution the
media constantly pay attention to
president from slurpee they should but
standards twitter feed is far more
idiotic ille and ideologically it's
actually more dangerous I'm
in schapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
so tons to get to today obviously lots
of breaking news from the hill we will
talk about what's happening at the komi
hearing on the hill with the House
Intelligence Committee and from Prussia
ties and and Trump's accusations of
Obama wiretapping we'll also talk
briefly about the gorse insurance will
save some of that for tomorrow because
they're happening contemporaneously with
the show today but we have lots to get
to even beyond that but first we have to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
blue aprons so if you want a good solid
home-cooked meal healthy top-notch but
you actually don't know how to cook you
know anything about cooking you don't
know how to shop for the best
ingredients that's what blue apron is
for so blue apron has established
partnerships with all these farms and
Fisheries and ranchers across the United
States and they send you all of the best
ingredients with the recipes so that you
can make all the meals on your own and
it is the best home cooking system
available on the market today not only
just cooking build better family bonds a
lot of fun I do with my daughter of time
it also means that you are going to
spend more time with family and the food
is better because their aprons are
recipes are created by blue apron the
ingredients are shipped to you in the
proper quantity and some of their
upcoming meals have a different recipe
every night and they never repeat the
recipe so listen that some which is
great I mean if you're someone like me
who's stuck in a rut of having the same
thing every Tuesday night boo apron
breaks that up for you here are some of
their upcoming meal salmon piccata with
orzo and broccoli vegetable chili and
baked sweet potatoes with crispy
tortilla strips I mean this is top-notch
stuff everybody I know is using blue
apron calm and it's affordable for less
than ten dollars per person per meal
they deliver those seasonal recipes
along with proportion ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meals they
say there's variety and it's guaranteed
if something comes and it's not ready to
cook they will make it right for you
right now if you go to blue aprons calm
/ shapiro blue aprons calm / shapiro you
get those first three meals free with
free shipping like a thirty dollar value
by going to blue apron calm / shapiro
you will love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue apron don't wait it's
blue aprons calm / shapiro blue aprons
icons flash apparel blue apron is the
best way to cook okay so lots happening
on the hill today so we will start with
that not a good hearing
our president from on the hill today so
James Comey the director of the FBI and
the in the National Security
Administration head who is Admiral Mike
Rogers they both basically came out and
they said that Trump is is full of crap
when it comes to Obama wiretapping him
now that doesn't mean that there were
not Trump associates caught up in
wiretaps of Russians it doesn't mean
that Trump associates were not wiretap
themselves although we have no evidence
of that it does mean that trumps
accusation the President Obama
wiretapped him or that he wiretap Trump
Tower again there is no evidence at all
that this is true so you know the idea
that Trump keeps promoting it and keeps
doubling down on it he's destroying his
own public trust with this thing at this
point so comee came out and first Comey
said there was no evidence at all he
says I have no information that supports
these tweets we have looked fully within
the FBI he said the DOJ had no
information supporting president Trump's
tweets either he said no president could
order a wiretap anyway because all
electronic surveillance works through
the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act courts which is not a surprise
because top Democrats and Republicans in
the House and the Senate have already
said they have no evidence to
substantiate from sweet there were the
accusations last week by Judge
Napolitano on Fox News that British
intelligence had been working with Obama
to wiretap Trump the national security
administration had Mike Rogers he said
an open testimony that any allegations
that the British did this were quote
utterly ridiculous so there are all
these reports from infowars that there
were documents that were going to come
out showing that obama had wiretap trump
that appears to be at least according to
this testimony a bunch of crap which is
not surprising infowars tends to report
things that are not true more often than
than other news sources and people buy
into stuff because they feel like it
confirms their pre-existing notions
there is a significant amount of
confirmation bias and how people view
the news and so this is not good for
Trump now does this mean that the
intelligence community leaking about
Trump is anything decent no it doesn't
and so you have dueling narratives now
the narrative that you get from the left
is the Trump was full of crap about the
Obama wiretaps and the narrative that
you have from the right from from people
like you know people like me and people
like the folks on fox news is that these
one of these leaks regarding the
information about the Trump team and
Russia and all of that there's no reason
that should be out in front and that's
true there's something deeply awkward
and wrong about having the FBI director
going out there and discussing active
investigations this is also true during
the campaign Republicans don't have a
huge led to stand on here because they
were perfectly happy to watch James
Comey come out and reveal that there was
an ongoing investigation into Hillary
Clinton when there was actually no
evidence that he ended up providing
demonstrating additional proof of
Hillary's guilt beyond that which we
already knew in July when he basically
exonerated her James Comey is a terrible
FBI director then we're going to put
that out front James Comey the FBI
director is awful at his job he can't
shut his face he obviously wants to
stick his foot into every public pie
that is available so there are really
two pieces of breaking news from the
coma hearings one Trump's allegations
about the wiretapping at Trump Tower no
evidence of those whatsoever is that
going to stop people from believing it
no and we'll get to that in a problem in
a second because that is a major problem
is the idea that if you're rooting for
someone the truth is secondary we've now
been discussing this for well over a
year it's true among conservatives it's
from one leftist the idea that truth is
secondary to victory is something that's
being promulgated at the highest levels
including from president Trump it's also
being promulgated on the left you have
president Trump who says things like if
CNN runs a poll I don't like that's only
because CNN is a failing news outlet
they're losers basically the ratings
suck equating success with truth and
then on the left you have people
equating equating success with Ruth in
other words if they get away with saying
that Trump is an illegitimate president
even if it's not true then that makes it
okay right the ends justify the means
has become not just in ancillary part of
politics but the core of politics on
both sides and it's a really really
nasty negative thing so that's a piece
of news number one piece of news number
two is that combing confirmed that the
FBI has been since July investigating
the Trump Russia connections okay which
is not great okay not not a great thing
that means that both presidential
candidates in the last election cycle
you want to ride and vote for either of
them both presidential candidates in the
last election cycle were under active
investigation by the FBI both of them or
at least their people were okay Hillary
Clinton was under investigation because
we're emails and Donald Trump's team was
under investigation apparently here is
what Comey said quote the FBI as part of
our
counterintelligence mission is
investigating the Russian government's
efforts to interfere in the 2016
presidential election and that includes
investigating the nature of any links
between individuals associated with the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government and whether there was any
coordination between the campaign and
Russia's efforts now we have to stop
there for a second Comey at no point
said that he had uncovered evidence of
actual collusion between the Trump team
and the Russians as far as expecting the
election now Democrats have been out
front saying that there is the seed
collusion it's obvious it's open to
anybody and they're pointing at people
like Paul Manafort and saying well Paul
Manafort was Trump's campaign manager
Paul Manafort actually worked for
Vladimir Putin what more do you need
them that what you do need more than
that if you actually want to have
criminal charges or if you want to claim
that the election was actually impacted
in a deep way by mana Ford who is out
pretty early on in the election cycle
and replaced by Steve benen and
Kellyanne Conway so the idea that that
mana fort was the guy who was behind
everything that this is all some sort of
big Russian plants are they're
suspicious ties between Trump campaign
officials in Russia yes does that mean
that the tides extend the Trump no it
doesn't it's quite possible that Trump
who is admittedly an ignoramus about the
political system that he just hired
somebody who is seen as sort of a black
ops 2 artists which is what manna fort
was seen as he hired him and then he
found out the Nana fort had ties to the
Russians and then he had to fire room
that's actually quite plausible so the
idea of this extends all the way up to
trump and that there was active
collusion between Trump's people and the
Russians in order to affect the election
on Trump's behalf that Comey actually
said in this hearing there's no evidence
that these shift in the Republican
National Committee in the Republican
National Committee platform there the
shifts with regard to Ukraine and Russia
he said there's no evidence that that is
tied in any way to Russian influence so
you know a lot of this is speculation on
the part of Democrats so what we've got
on both sides now is speculation on
behalf of scandals that really are not
materializing we have speculation on
behalf of scandals that are really not
materializing on both sides on the one
side you have people on the right
speculating that Trump was a victim of
Obama s wiretapping and that this is the
end of the world and they're just
basically at this point speculating
they're basically just throwing stuff
out there without a lot of evidence to
back it up and on the other side you
have the Democrats speculating that
Trump is some sort of Russian plant
without any evidence
to back it up and so what you end up
with is a bunch of innuendo and nobody
trusts each other and nobody knows what
the hell is going on and that is not a
good state for government could be in at
this point in time it's not that you
should trust the government I don't
think you should trust the government
I'm in favor of limited government and I
wish that all of this massive distrust
in government actually led to people
saying okay well let's make the
government that I don't trust what's
involved in my life unfortunately what
it seems to be doing is the opposite in
a lot of ways which is I don't trust the
government therefore if we put in charge
someone that I do trust then everything
will work out just fine and that's not
right okay that's not right because just
because you trust Trump doesn't mean
he's telling you the truth just because
you trusted Obama didn't mean that he
was telling you the truth they all have
their own agenda and the agenda at no
point seems to cross paths even remotely
with the truth so you know that's that's
disastrous just to give you some
evidence that this is how people are
thinking now Adam Schiff who is one of
the people who was doing the questioning
during this latest Comey hearing here's
the anima chef talking about the level
of circumstantial evidence of collusion
between the Trump campaign in Russia
look collusion is is sort of what hasn't
been proven here between whatever the
Russians did and the Trump campaign in
fact the former acting director of the
CIA who was a Mike Morell who was a
supporter of Hillary Clinton he
essentially reminded people took
director clapper at his word on this
show who said there has been no evidence
that has been found of collusion are we
at the point of at what point do you
start to wonder if there is a fired all
the smoke well first of all I was
surprised see director clapper say that
because I don't think you can make that
claim categorically as he did I would
characterize it this way at the outside
of the investigation there is
circumstantial evidence of collusion
there is direct evidence I think of
deception and that's where we begin the
investigation now I don't want to
prejudge where we ultimately end up and
of course there's one thing to say
there's evidence there's another thing
to say we can prove this or prove it
beyond a reasonable doubt or there's
enough evidence to bring to a grand jury
for purposes of criminal indictment but
there is certainly enough for us to
conduct investigation the American
people have a right to know and in order
to defend ourselves we need to know
whether these the circumstantial
evidence of collusion and direct
evidence of deception is indicative of
more I assume the direct evidence of
deception he's talking about his Mike
Flynn admitting that he talked to the
Russians when he said he hadn't talked
to the Russians but you know again this
is just paper thin it's just a tissue
it's just a tissue and then you have
called me out there substantiating the
tissue with nothing to back it and so
this is just going to lead to more
speculation this is why the intelligence
community needs to stop talking okay the
intelligence community should not be out
front discussing active investigations
this is commis fault it is often the
fault of a very very leaky intelligence
community that hates Donald Trump so
that is a third scandal and maybe the
biggest one and maybe the biggest
problem because the more information
comes out that is unsubstantiated and
there's no way to substantiate it the
more people are not going to trust
either side and they're going to go back
to their respective corners and the
Republicans will talk to trump and trust
him and the Democrats will talk to
Schumer and trust him and nobody in the
center will actually have any place to
go and nobody will know what the truth
is because the people who are supposed
to be investigating the truth keep
dripping out little pieces of
information that are not helpful in any
way and that is Jim's commis fault that
is James commis problem and so I don't
think the Republicans are wrong when
they when they say that all of these
leaks are disaster Eric trump you know
he was saying that leaking from stacks
is the problem he's right leaking
Trump's taxes is a problem you know
Sarah Lee said there were an environment
where you know tax returns are leaked by
you know whoever it may be in I'm going
to just just think about it I mean just
think about how dangerous that is how
third world that is of a practice that
happened when personal information is
being put out by people for political
agendas and it's a as a civilian
affection scary to me okay and it should
be scary and I think the Derek Trump is
right here Rand Paul says the same thing
he says that there should be some
investigation into the leakers regarding
Michael Flynn and his calls with Russia
the intelligence community should not be
leaking information on active
investigations I think that we know one
thing for sure that the Obama
administration did spy on Flynn now
whether it was direct or indirect
somebody was reading and taking a con a
transcript of his phone calls and then
they released it it is very very
important that whoever at least that go
to jail
fail because you cannot have members of
the intelligence community listening to
the most private and highly classified
information and then releasing that to
the New York Times there can only there
is true as well so again just to recap
there are three scandals okay there's
one that's real and two that really are
not so real there's one that's real is
the leaking scandal because it is
obvious members of the intelligence
community should not be leaking
information that is against the law it
is against the law and there's a problem
it was a problem during the campaign it
was a problem for Hillary Clinton it's a
problem now okay all of it is a problem
and James Comey does not make it any
better I think I think homie has to go
then on the other hand you have two
other scandals both of which seem to be
paper-thin and following a part one is
Trump saying that Obama wire captain
paper-thin but Republicans believe in
any way and the other is Trump in Russia
we're colluding paper-thin but Democrats
believe it anyway none of this is good
for our politics and then there's
something else that's really bad for our
politics that I'll discuss in just a
second but first I have to say thank you
to our advertisers over at my Patriot
supply so right now North Korea won't
shut up okay North Korea keep saying
over and over there going to nuke us and
you may not believe them until it's time
for them to new don't worry about
natural disaster either until the
natural disaster has already happened
you don't worry too much about an
earthquake or a flood or a hurricane
until it's too late and is hit you and
all the grocery stores are cleaned out
and you don't have anywhere to get the
food and the government can't get to you
and that's why you need to go to prepare
with been calm right now prepare with
Ben dot-com or call eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen and get
your four weeks supply of emergency food
888 803 1413 this is just the cautious
and proper thing to do prepare what's
been calm a four-week emergency food
supply for only ninety nine dollars it
lasts forever it lasts forever what is
it 20 years and and that means that
you're only going to have to do this
once so go to just go do it put it in
your closet forget about it until it's
time for you use the food supply that
you were smart enough to buy in advance
prepare with been calm 888 803 14 13 and
apparel and food tastes really good
actually i was told that by people in
the office who have tasted it prepared
with been calm 8888 03 14 13 you never
worry about an emergency until it's too
late right now you can get this off your
mind right now she's go to prepare what
that
calm right now or that and before week
emergency food supply you never have to
worry about it again and that's the way
it should work okay so there is
something else really nasty happening in
politics and that is we're undermining
trust from both sides because we've
barricaded ourselves and our own
narrative without actually looking at
the evidence is there evidence that
Trump colluded with Russia not so much
is there evidence that Obama wiretap
Trump not so much and so we barricade
ourselves in our sides we just look for
confirming information and that's
exacerbated by all the social media
which have algorithms that benefit sites
that are like the ones you look at so if
you tend to look at sites on the right
you're going to be promoted to more
sites on the right and that means that
you are further ensconced in this bubble
but the biggest problem I think is that
our politicians just keep lying to us
they just keep lying for their own
political benefit and then the promises
they make never materialized which
undermines trust on a grand scale Roland
Martin was talking about the fact that
Trump care is now going to be up for a
vote and Trump care should be a provide
against this thursday in the house Trump
has been promising for a long time
nobody is going to lose their health
insurance health insurance is going to
be available for everyone he's been
using Democrat language to talk about
Trump care for a very long time about
health insurance for a very long time
and you made a bunch of promises that
this bill is just not going to guarantee
because Trump was talking in terms that
the bill doesn't guarantee Roland Martin
is a Democrat says this but he's not
wrong here is you've been had you've
been took you've been hoodwinked
bamboozled let us pray run a month to
look wash these white working-class
voters upset and mad saying I voted for
you and I'm going we tried to tell you
this is what the Maine State he was
going to do now they're faced with a
backlash oh now they'll all be
affordable care act and not Republican
IMF okay and he is not wrong than when
you make promises to people and he can't
fulfill those promises that undermines
trust on 2010 Republicans said that they
were going to repeal and replace
Obamacare they didn't in 2012 they said
they were going to do it in 2014 they
said they were going to do in 2016 they
say they're going to do it and then the
planet they proposed doesn't actually do
it so I want to talk about the damage
that it does when Republicans make
promises to the white working class and
to the working class general as much as
white working class that they cannot
keep and whether that makes a difference
or not we'll talk about can Republicans
win by telling the truth I think that is
the big question
in all of this just generally from the
scandals to trump care I think the
biggest question right now can
Republicans win by telling the truth or
is truth an obstacle to victory and that
means the truth has to go out the window
in favor of some sort of higher truth
well which is victory for central
principles of conservatism that is I
think the great battle at the heart at
the beating heart of what's going on in
the conservative movement right now but
in order for you to hear that we're
going to go over to daily wire calm and
become a subscriber eight dollars a
month get a new subscription today lee
weyer calm if you become an annual
subscriber right now then you get a free
copy of reasons to vote Democrat a
comprehensive guide is entirely thorough
by Michael moles it is 266 pages of
goodness you can check it out reasons to
vote Democrat a comprehensive guide it
is the number one best seller on amazon
was for like a week and a half it sold
tens of thousands of copies you can get
it for free signed by our very own
Michael Mills that genius yell historian
go over and check it out you can get the
eight dollar annual subscription the
eight dollars per month annual
subscription right now means that you
get the copy of Michael Melissa's new
book or if you just want to listen to
the rest of the show later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud llevo sort of view
in itunes we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you